It seems to be in the Korean Peninsula,
the drums of war are constantly
rumbling,
certainly true that this area is not
known for its peacefulness,
but the kind of tension that the area
has been recently feeling has not
existed for some time.
The United States,
the country which already had 30,000
soldiers deployed in the area,
has also deployed several aircraft
carriers,
heavy bombers,
and even advanced anti missile system in
South Korea.
It is so advanced that China has even
considered it a threat to their own
security,
trying to tells us to remove antimissile
key h,
a d system from South Korea amid spying
fears.
North Korea on the other hand,
keeps carrying out a new tests with
ballistic missiles and is progressing
with its nuclear program.
It seems that North Korea doesn't really
care about all the international
legislation about nonproliferation and
nuclear testing.
Japan and South Korea are feeling
understandably temps.
They want to know what to do,
what decisions to make step by step in
order to stop the growing threat.
That is Kim Jong.
UHM,
North Korea.
His most recent missile launch is
absolutely intolerable.
You'll need to take a stand.
We already told you in a previous video
here at visual politic about how Japan
is seriously considering putting an end
to the pacifists nature of their
constitution and it seems that right
now,
even Beijing has had enough of Pyongyang
quarterly,
sent a 150,000 troops to North Korea's
border.
If this story were a movie,
I'd probably leave the center and
thinking that the writer had taken too
much creative liberty
dynamic.
What is really happening in this region?
What can we actually expect?
Well,
that's what we're going to talk about in
this visual politic video,
but before we get into all of that,
let's get some perspective.
Where are we and how did we get to the
situation in North Korea is some sort of
nightmare from the past.
It's a country still living in the cold
water country with one of the most
totalitarian governments in the world,
and along with all of that,
it's also one of the poorest countries
on the planet.
According to the United Nations.
Two out of five North Korean suffer from
undernourishment buckskin.
Joe [inaudible],
the guy who controls the country with an
iron fist,
doesn't seem to give a damn about any of
that site.
It is estimated the Pyongyang started to
develop its nuclear program around the
19 eighties and since then there have
been a few key situations which have
sped up this progress.
The first was the fall,
the Soviet Union in 1991.
Then game George W dot Bush's
incorporation of North Korea into these
so called axis of evil in 2002.
Then the was the coming to power of Kim
Jong EU in 2011.
We could say that every time the regime
felt threatened,
they decided to accelerate the process.
Bob,
so we're going to discuss that later in
the video.
The issue is today,
it is estimated that North Korea holds
from 10 to 20 nuclear weapons and
according to the Rand Corporation,
if it doesn't stop producing them,
the North Korean program could
accumulate around 100 nuclear bombs by
the year 20,
20.
But do you wait for just a second
because this isn't the end of the story,
but now the technology used in this
country as well?
It's pretty basic.
It's based on old designs from the
Soviet Union,
so the bombs they have developed up
until now,
they don't work.
Brilliant.
Yeah.
That is why Pyongyang is now obsessed
with two things.
On the one hand,
attempting to miniaturize the bombs so
they can be placed in missiles.
On the other hand is developing
ballistic missiles capable of attacking
targets that all thousands of miles
away.
The last tests they've conducted
indicate that they are probably making
some important advances.
Many analysts,
including the intelligence services of
South Korea and the United States have
considered the North Korea is already
capable of weaponizing short and mid
range missiles with nuclear warheads
which could allow them to reach South
Korea and Japan.
That's not all.
It seems clear that if the program
doesn't stop in a few years,
North Korea will be capable of attacking
the United States of America with
ballistic missiles.
This would be a significant strategic
leap for North Korea and that difference
is a red line.
Which is causing the Pentagon many,
many headaches.
So now you might be wondering,
well,
hasn't the US done anything to stop this
country as well?
The truth is that they have tried almost
every
us strategy.
Yes,
the United States and South Korea have
trying to persuade Pyongyang to abandon
that plan of developing nuclear weapons
and well,
they didn't have any problem taking out
a checkbook in order to do this
in the early nineties,
1994 to be specific,
Bill Clinton signed the agreement
framework by which North Korea committed
to cancel it's military plans in
exchange for generous fueled help from
the United States,
as well as assistance to build two
nuclear reactors for civilian use.
With this disagreements,
North Korea obtains the energy they
needed to develop that economy.
As for South Korea,
besides giving a huge amount of
humanitarian aid,
they also committed to boost and finance
North Korea's economic development
programs.
It all seem to be going well for a
while.
However,
it all fills pieces in 2002.
When George W dot Bush founds out that
Pyongyang had been fooling them in
secret North Korea at kept developing
its nuclear programs for military
purposes.
After more negotiations,
they reached a new agreements and Bush's
administration restarted their age
program and lifted sanctions spots.
A year later,
Pyongyang reneged on the deal.
Despite all of this,
Barack Obama decided to try yet again in
February 2012,
they reach a new agreement.
North Korea canceled the nuclear program
and the United States restarted once
again the economic game.
This time Pyongyang broke the agreement
only six weeks later.
All right,
so now you're beginning to get the
picture.
So now you might be wondering,
well,
why a North Korea?
So insistence on having nuclear weapons
at all,
what are each looking for?
The regime of Kim Jong UN is pretty set
on developing more advanced nuclear
weapons and the international community
is going to have to get used to the idea
that this is not something they are
going to abandon,
but that still leaves us with the
question of why.
Well,
first of all,
because they think that nuclear weapons
are essential for the survival.
Young young knows that with nuclear
weapons around no foreign power,
especially the United States,
would dat intervene in the country
when the United States invaded Iraq,
North Korean leaders,
they were paying attention,
but then the first mistake Saddam
Hussein made was not having nuclear
weapons and other wmds.
They thought the same thing.
When Gaddafi's regime fell,
there'd be a voluntarily canceled it's
program for the development of wmds a
few years earlier,
so the North Korean leadership thinks,
and so honestly that probably right,
that nuclear weapons are the best
guarantee to staying in power.
Further,
the sales of nuclear weapons technology
is one of the main sources of foreign
currency coming into the country
currency that's needed so the elite can
maintain their standards of living since
the fall of the Soviet Union.
North Korea has become one of the main
exporters of missile equipment
technology and components.
USC says North Korean ship taking
missiles to Yemen.
Also,
indications are that North Korea has
sold nuclear technology to Iran and
advised Syria in the construction of a
nuclear reactor that Israel bombarded in
2007 is really strike targeted Syrian
nuclear reactor.
The Telegraph,
it is precisely this risk of
proliferation,
which is why the United States is trying
so hard to stop North Korea.
The other reason is,
of course,
do you try to prevent this country from
being capable of threatening the United
States with a nuclear attack so well now
we come to China and what China thinks
of all of this
China.
One
thing is if it weren't for trying to
support North Korea would have never
developed its nuclear and it isn't just
the technological part that we're
talking about here or the support to
avoid international penalties.
It's also the money trying to accounts
for more than 90 percent of North
Korea's total trade daily and k.
In other words,
without the support of Beijing,
this country,
it would have collapsed a long time ago.
However,
there are some signs which tell us
China,
well,
they're a bit tied up so much
provocation because they're not happy
about this nuclear missiles either.
It could be said for Beijing killing
Yang is now a burden that China has to
deal with as it attempts to gain
influence and leadership in
international politics.
Trying to take the driver's seat on free
trade.
Some analysts have even suggested the
Beijing might be losing control over the
government of Pyongyang,
which is now self absorbed by then new
nuclear capability.
Importantly,
for the first time in November of 2006,
China agreed to completely stick with
the international sanctions being
leveled against North Korea.
Besides in the last few months.
China is forbid a North Korean coal
imports and gas exports and weld.
The international community is holding
its breath.
That is a significant punishments that
Kim Jong,
Uhm,
regime ams wealth is more international
relations between these two countries is
not at its best points.
In fact,
since Kim Jong Un women came to power,
no top level bilateral meetings have
taken place.
And now less and less official visits
between the countries.
So the question is,
is Beijing really changing its
relationship with Pyong Yang?
Yeah,
a road to solution.
It is still to seemed tonight,
but don't be fooled for the time being.
China is not going to let North Korea
fall,
which is still an ally for them in the
region,
at least not until they have serious
reasons to do so.
That is a key point to understand.
If we want to find a solution to this
crisis,
China needs to be persuaded to try and
make Pyongyang put an end to this,
cancel their nuclear program and carry
out real reforms,
but that winds happen under the current
setup.
That is why many experts think it is
time for the United States to withdraw
from Korea and consider dismantling the
anti missile system and perhaps consider
some economic compensation as well.
It is also important that China
understands that the current situation
might need South Korea and Japan to
pursue an arms race as well as the
option of developing that own nuclear
weapons.
So now we've told you our opinion here
at visual politic and we'd love to know
what you think.
Click here if you.
Once you leave your opinion in a quick
survey.
So what do you think trump's
administration should do?
Do you think North Korea should put an
end to its nuclear plans?
Should they even possibly be threatened
with war?
Well,
I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do hit that subscribe button
below the video and stay tuned for new
videos every Monday and Thursday and do
not forget to check out and reconsider
media podcast.
They actually provided the voice for
this video that isn't mine,
and as always,
I'll see you in the next video.